[Musique]
accord entre l'iran et l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
concernant le matériel de surveillance
l'eeie a va pouvoir intervenir sur
l'équipement nucléaire le but est
d'assurer la continuité dans la
surveillance du programme nucléaire
iranien
une implication saoudienne dans les
attentats du 11 septembre c'est ce
qu'évoque une note du fbi à elle vient
d'être déclassifiées à l'occasion du 20e
anniversaire des attentats et cette note
n'apporte aucune preuve sur
l'implication de ryad on en parle dans
ce journal
et puis la présence américaine en
afghanistan aura duré 20 ans le retrait
des troupes devaient ouvrir à une
nouvelle ère mais sur place c'est plutôt
le retour en arrière les talibans sont
maintenant au pouvoir depuis un mois la
situation humanitaire est préoccupante
[Musique]
je
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france
on commence avec le dossier du nucléaire
avec cet accord trouvé entre l'iran et
les yeux assure le matériel de
surveillance les inspecteurs de l'agencé
internationale ont désormais
l'autorisation d'intervenir pour
entretenir l'équipement pour les yeux à
l'intérêt et de continuera à surveiller
le programme nucléaire iranien les
précisions de françois xavier lambert
il est venu en personne pour relancer
des négociations qui n'avançait plus à
téhéran le directeur général de l'aiea
et le chef de l'organisation iranienne
de l'énergie atomique ont enfin trouvé
un terrain d'entente sur une question
cruciale la surveillance vidéo des
installations iraniennes alors que
l'iran a restera en février l'accès des
inspecteurs de l'agencé à certains de
ces sites ces derniers pourront
désormais y pénétrer pour mettre à jour
des équipements l'eeie a craignez de
perdre les données en cas de saturation
de la mémoire des caméras de
surveillance installées
aujourd'hui nous sommes en mesure
d'avoir un résultat très concrets
qui permet la continuité du
fonctionnement des équipements de
lagence
[Musique]
c'est indispensable pour que nous
puissions fournir les garanties et les
informations nécessaires à la loi
ainsi qu'au monde entier que tout est en
ordre
cet accord marque une timide avancée
pour les yeux a même si l'iran refuse
toujours de fournir les données des
caméras
nous avons convenu que pour changer les
cartes mémoires des caméras de
surveillance l'équipe technique concerné
via en iran après l'accord afin qu'ils
puissent faire les mesures techniques
nécessaires pour les caméras
et les cartes mémoires selon l'accord
seront scellé et conservé en iran
ces négociations se tiennent en
parallèle des pourparlers de vienne
visant à relancer l'accord international
sur le nucléaire iranien un accord qui
offre à téhéran un allègement des
sanctions occidentales en échange d'une
réduction drastique de son programme
nucléaire après le retrait américain des
négociations annoncées par donald trump
en 2018 téhéran a décidé de ne plus
respecter ses obligations depuis les
etats unis ont accepté de revenir à la
table des discussions des discussions de
nouveau suspendue deux jours après la
victoire à la présidentielle iranienne
débrayera ici le 18 juin dernier
et on en parlait tout à l'heure avec
thierry coville chercheur à l'institut
de relations internationales et
stratégiques et spécialiste de l'iran
selon lui le gouvernement iranien à la
volonté d'honorer cet accord écouter
on a un nouveau gouvernement en iran qui
est quand même beaucoup moins pro
occidental que le précédent kébou qui
pend et qui veut vraiment négocier très
durement mais d'un autre côté on sent
bien aussi que les radicaux en iran qui
ont tiré à boulet rouge sur cet accord
maintenant ils disent il a été signée
faut le respecter donc on sent bien
aussi qu'il ya une volonté en iran si
toutes les sanctions économiques sont
levés de revenir dans l'accord du côté
américain il aimerait bien régler ce
problème là pour au moins diminuer les
tensions avec l'iran d'avis et la clé
des relations de l'iran avec le reste du
monde cet accord de sur l'éclair donc
les états unis l'ont bien compris donc
je pense qu'il est il ya il ya une
volonté d'aboutir à un accord du côté
iranien et américain alors ensuite
qu'est ce que ça va donner dans les
négociations
chaque sous l'ailé du côté iranien
notamment ils vont ils veulent plus
faire de concession donc les
négociations pour est dure mais disons
bon on veut dire on sent une envie quand
même du côté iranien côté américain d'un
soutien monaco
bref gaye a déclassifié une note
évoquant l'implication de l'arabie
saoudite dans les attentats du 11
septembre cette note qui n'apportent
aucune preuve des cris des liens entre
un agent saoudien présumé qui était
installé en californie et deux pirates
de l'air qui ont détourné des avions de
ligne le 11 septembre 2001 il est
soupçonné de leur avoir apporté une aide
logistique cette note a donc été
déclassifiés après des pressions
exercées sur joe biden par des familles
de victimes qui poursuivent l'arabie
saoudite pour complicité dans
l'organisation des attentats parmi les
19 pirates de l'air qui ont détourné les
quatre avions de ligne ce jour là 15
étaient des ressortissants saoudiens à
ce propos écoutez l'analyse de régis le
sommier grand reporter pour rt france
les 19 sur les 19 kamikazes du
11-septembre je crois de mémoire comme
il y en a deux qui en a un qui est
libanais et à bord d'une autre
nationalité de coeur mohammed atta qui
égyptiens les autres son immunité
saoudien donc on est on est quand même
donc des pilotes d'ailleurs donc on est
quand même avec une représentation des
saoudiens en tout cas de la péninsule
arabique absolument énorme dans dans la
lah la préparation et c'est des gens qui
ont été formés comment recruter entraîné
kandar donc sur une d1 des camps
d'al-qaïda avant le 11 septembre et donc
voilà donc il y avait quand même et puis
il ya le tout les relations assez obscur
entre les services de renseignements
saoudiens les talibans d'une part et al
qaïda voilà donc je pense que ce que
veulent ce que veulent ces survivances
et ça c'est faire un petit peu comment
l'éclairage ou en tout cas la lumière
sur ce qu'elle a pu être le rôle de kate
qu'elles ont évoqué les ont pu être
la part finalement prises par un certain
nombre de saoudiens dans ces attentats
une déclassification qui je vous disais
coïncide avec les 20 ans du 11-septembre
hier un hommage a été rendu aux victimes
de ces attentats ce jour là des
kamikazes membres d'al-qaïda détourné
quatre avions deux se sont écrasés sur
les tours jumelles du world trade center
hier la cérémonie officielle d'ailleurs
eu lieu au mémorial du new york qualité
présidée par joe biden auprès de lui
entre autres les deux anciens présidents
démocrates barack obama et bill clinton
concernant d'offres d'abou du boucher
donald trump cette journée de
commémoration a été l'occasion pour eux
de critiquer les actions de joe biden
surtout en ce qui concerne le retrait
des troupes américaines d'afghanistan
yamina benguigui da et marion caudal
des commémorations teintées de critiques
contre joe biden à l'initiative de deux
anciens présidents américains george w
bush et donald trump
le premier dénonce l'absence d'unité
dans un contexte de défiance vis-à-vis
de la classe politique aux etats-unis
en grande partie de notre politique est
devenue un appel brut à la colère à la
peur et à la rancoeur
cela nous rend inquiet pour notre nation
et notre avenir commun
donald trump lui pointe ce qu'il appelle
les chèques de joe biden lors du retrait
des troupes américaines d'afghanistan
c'est le 20e anniversaire de cette
guerre et cela aurait dû être l'année de
la victoire de l'honneur de la force au
lieu de cela joe biden et son
administration inapte on transformer
cela en défaite
pourtant c'est donald trump lui même qui
scellait le 26 février 2020 avec les
talibans un accord pour fixer
l'opération à la mi mai de la même année
soit presque dix ans après les premières
annonces de son prédécesseur barack
obama à l'origine de cette intervention
en afghanistan
la décision de george w.bush d'autres
est en guerre contre l' axe du mal après
les attaques du 11 septembre 2001 et
alors que les talibans refusé de livrer
les dirigeants d'al qaïda aux autorités
américaines face aux journalistes
joe biden a répondu aux critiques
lancées à son rencontre le président
américain a rappelé que les etats-unis
ne pouvaient envahir chaque pays ou des
chats étaient présents si vous aviez dit
à qui que ce soit que nous allions
dépensé 300 millions de dollars par jour
pendant 20 ans pour essayer d'unifier le
pays après avoir rattrapé ben laden
après avoir éliminer al-qaïda là bas et
ce qu al qaïda pourrait revenir oui mais
je vais vous le dire ils sont déjà de
retour dans d'autres endroits quelle est
la stratégie nous devons envahir tous
les endroits où se trouve al qaïda ils
essaient nos troupes soyons sérieux
la vice-présidente kamala harris a
également pris la parole pour appeler
les américains à s'unir comme en réponse
aux propos de bouche et de trump
après le 11 septembre nous avons pu voir
comment la peur peut être utilisé pour
semer la division dans notre nation
lorsque des américains sic et musulmans
ont été pris pour cible en raison de
leur apparence de leur culte
mais nous avons également vu ce qui se
passe lorsque tant d'américains dans
l'esprit de notre nation se sont montrés
solidaires de tous les peuples et de
leurs concitoyens de ceux qui subissent
la violence et la discrimination
vingt ans après les événements du 11
septembre et leurs conséquences
continuent d'agiter la classe politique
américaine et viennent rappeler les
nombreux échecs de l'interventionnisme
américain
et on passe à la situation en
afghanistan où les talibans sont donc au
pouvoir depuis un mois maintenant il
tente donc l'enchère une normalisation
économique un premier vol commercial
doit d'ailleurs relier à partir de
demain islamabad à kaboul un pont aérien
humanitaire a également été mise en
place entre les émirats arabes unis et
l'afghanistan concernant les évacuations
elle se poursuivre lentement en vol avec
à son bord des familles françaises est
parti de kaboul à doha vendredi le
ministre des affaires étrangères jean
yves le drian est d'ailleurs au qatar
jusqu'à demain
les talibans qui ont présenté leur
gouvernement cette semaine un exécutif
largement critiquée par les etats-unis
et l'union européenne en cause notamment
l'absence de femmes au sein de la
nouvelle équipe gouvernementale des
femmes qui se voit interdite de faire du
sport et qui pourrait étudier devront
porter le niqab et être séparées des
hommes malgré ses nombreuses
restrictions certaines d'entre elles
soutiennent les talibans les précisions
avec françois xavier lambert
ce sont près de 300 afghane vêtu dabaya
et de niqab qui défilent devant
l'université de kaboul
certaines d'entre elles tiennent le
drapeau blanc et noir des talibans on
signe de soutien au nouveau pouvoir
afghan depuis quelques jours dans le
pays les femmes ne peuvent plus assister
aux cours qu'à condition de porter un
long voile couvrant la totalité de leur
corps et de leur visage elles doivent
aussi être séparées des hommes alors que
de nombreuses manifestations contre ces
mesures ont été réprimées en afghanistan
des militantes assure soutenir ces
nouvelles règles inspirées de la charia
certaines personnes pensent que nous
avons perdu beaucoup de choses après que
l'amérique ait quitté l'afghanistan
comme l'argent les forces aériennes néo
droits de l'homme la liberté des femmes
la liberté de la presse et les relations
diplomatiques cependant ce n'est pas le
cas si l'on regarde les choses de
manière lucide cette manifestation
intervient alors que les talibans ont
annoncé dans la semaine la composition
de leur nouveau gouvernement une équipe
formée exclusivement de issu du
mouvement fondamentaliste et qui compte
désormais un ministre de la promotion et
de la vertu ainsi que de la répression
du vice le nouveau pouvoir de kaboul a
toutefois annoncé que certains postes
vacants pourraient être attribués à des
personnes plus représentatives du peuple
toutes les agences gouvernementales
n'ont pas encore été annoncés certains
postes ministériels directeurs et
adjoints restent vacants des efforts
sont en cours pour les pourvoir des
efforts sont également faits pour que
des personnes de différentes régions et
de tout le pays joue un rôle dans ce
processus
dirigé par un proche du fondateur des
talibans ce gouvernement compte aussi
d'anciens prisonniers de guantanamo
certains sont aussi visées par des
sanctions de l'onu dès l'annoncé de leur
gouvernement les talibans ont essuyé les
critiques des occidentaux
après une première analyse des noms
annoncés cela ne ressemble pas la
formation inclusive et représentatifs de
la riche diversité ethnique et
religieuse de l'afghanistan que nous
espérions voir et que les talibans
promettaient ces dernières semaines nous
comprenons que les talibans ont présenté
cela comme un cabinet intérimaire nous
les jugerons ainsi que sur ses actions
la communauté internationale a
clairement indiqué qu'elle s'attendait à
ce que les afghans mérite un
gouvernement inclusif
plus de trois semaines après leur prise
de pouvoir en afghanistan le programme
politique des talibans restent toujours
très flous les nouveaux maîtres du pays
devront rapidement convaincre la
communauté internationale sur leurs
intentions pour obtenir les aides
économiques d aide vitale pour l'un des
pays les plus pauvres de la planète
en
france l'obligation vaccinale des
soignants entre en vigueur mercredi le
pass sanitaire lui est toujours
obligatoire dans de nombreux lieux de la
vie quotidienne et les français qui sont
opposés était une nouvelle fois dans la
rue hier pour manifester 120 mille selon
les autorités qui dénonçait une
violation des libertés individuelles
quelques affrontements ont eu lieu avec
les forces de l'ordre le point avec yves
olivier b
des gaz lacrymogènes lancées contre les
manifestants en réponse à des tirs de
mortiers envoyé en direction des
policiers la situation a rarement été
aussi tendue dans un rassemblement
contre le pass sanitaires hier 121 mille
personnes ont défilé dans toute la
france dont dix neuf mille à paris selon
le ministère de l'intérieur plusieurs
dizaines d'individus ont été interpellés
trois membres des forces de l'ordre ont
été blessés pour son neuvième samedi de
mobilisation le mouvement anti passe
sanitaire bas de laine à son apogée le 7
août dernier il rassemblait jusqu'à deux
cent trente sept mille personnes mais
qu'importe pour les manifestants
toujours déterminé à défendre les droits
qu'ils estiment bafouée
c'est d'abord primes at war monsieur qui
sont pas vaccinés c'est une puisque ce
alors les empêche d'accéder à certains
nombre de lieux alors que mag on avait
dit que les lieux de la vie courante on
fume en aucun cas le passage iter
devrait demander c'est une intrusion
dans notre intimité parce que ça veut
dire qu'effectivement en fonction du pas
sans concession des vaccinés pas
vaccinés sur des copies palco vide et
c'est alors que jusqu'à présent en
france tout ce qui relevait de la santé
devait rester secret je suis pour cette
liberté d'être comment de pouvoir
choisir ce qui est bon pour nous je
lutte depuis des années à accompagner
les gens pour chercher ce qui est bon
pour eux à l'intérieur d'eux qu'ils le
trouvent tout seul
on va pas aller se faire emmener dans
une décision qui n'est pas la nôtre
dans les cortèges l'inquiétude est
palpable chez les soignants concernées
par l'obligation vaccinale qui doit
entrer en vigueur mercredi prochain pour
cette femme la mesure est très difficile
à encaisser on était à 8 à ne pas être
vaccinés ce ca de 10 et aller vite mais
en fait les 8 donc moi il ya dans cette
qui vont se faire vacciner pour être
beau pour en garder leur emploi parce
que effectivement c'est compliqué ça le
salève 2
moi je vais essayer de maintenir un
maximum mais
j'espère qu'il va se passer quelque peu
changé puisque donc on arrive à moi j'ai
pas remis de cette aventure c'est pour
moi c'est pas une vaccination sera pour
l'heure le gouvernement français ne
fléchit pas face à la pression populaire
et au refus d'une partie des soignants
de se soumettre à ce passe au risque
d'être suspendu reste à savoir si
l'hémorragie prévisible de personnel
dans les hôpitaux le fera changer d'avis
l'extension de passes annie terre dans
l'est de la vie quotidienne on en a
parlé avec pierre gentille et il était
notre invité tout à l'heure il est
avocat au barreau de paris écouter
l'atteinte aux libertés fondamentales si
oui en fait elle est manifeste elle
n'est même pas contestée par le conseil
constitutionnel au conseil au ciel a
considéré à tort d'après moi que cette
atteinte au leader mental était
proportionné aux regards l'objectif à
atteindre cet acte préserver la santé
mais rappelons-nous encore une fois que
nous ne sommes pas passés à la peste
noire que nous sommes face à un virus
qui tue certes mais qui tue près peu en
proportion la population et qui touchait
certains cas théoriques relation est
encore une fois rappelons nous
aujourd'hui nous avons vis-à-vis de ces
populations une arme vis-à-vis du public
pour agir qui est le vaccin donc parti
au moment où la majorité des personnes
vulnérables l'extrême majorité des
personnes vulnérables 126 ne pas dire la
totalité
beaucoup moins de monde en réanimation
une hospitalisation et le reste de la
population
ça ne sert à rien
l'actualité en france s'était également
marquée cette semaine par les trois
premiers jours d'audience dans le procès
des attentats du 13 novembre 2015 vive
émotion chez les témoins et les proches
des victimes tandis que salar abdeslam a
joué la provocation les détails avec
médiers ce que fit
une salle saisie par l'émotion ce
vendredi des visages expressifs qui
démontre la douleur des familles et des
témoins le président de la cour
d'assises énonce les noms et l'âge des
victimes des attentats du 13 novembre
2015 un silence interminable traverse
l'hémicycle lorsque le magistrat
rappelle l'effroyable chronologie de la
tragédie qui a causé la mort 230
personnes
21h16 première explosion stade de france
21h20 deuxième explosion stade de france
21h24 première fusillade au crayon et
aux petits cambodge 21h26 deuxième
fusillade à la bonne bière et au faso
nostra 21h36 troisième fusillade la
belle équipe 21h41 explosion comptoir
voltaire 21h47 début de l'attaqué au
bataclan
21h53 troisième explosion au stade de
france lors des deux premiers jours
d'audience salle abdeslam a multiplié
les provocations les témoins des
attentats de 2015 se disent préparées à
ce genre de comportement de la part du
terroriste lors des prochaines semaines
sa première réaction pour moi un a donné
le la donc je vous cache pas que
je me suis un peu préparé je me suis
préparé à la fois son silence mais je me
suis préparé aussi aux réactions qu'il
peut y avoir parce que je pense que rang
de sur-réaction pour pas resté neuf mois
dans le cadre d'un procès et ne pas
réagir à la fois pour témoignages et je
témoignerai fait partie des deux témoins
15 ans darbord hors norme
des propos hallucinants
déclaré qu on a ni père ni mère à leur
père je veux bien mais mr ça me semble
un peu osé donc il est le fils de allah
c'est ce qu'il voulait dire
le renvoyer le fils de mal à ça dit tout
et ça ne laisse augurer d'aucune
donc une mon avis coopération future
dans le déroulement du procès qu'est-ce
qu'il va justifier en quoi va-t-il se
minimiser son implication il peut pas
réellement ya trop de charges ya trop de
preuves au total sur les vins accusé
douze pourrait être condamné à la
réclusion à perpétuité
mais avant le verdict de longues étapes
sont attendus plusieurs avocats se dit
satisfait de la forme du procès entamé
le mois de novembre va être consacrée à
la personnalité des accusés on va
véritablement entrer dans les faits
pouvoir écouter les enquêteurs leur
poser des questions contesté critiquer
la manière d' avoir investigué les
choses éventuellement pour certains
d'entre nous c'est simplement mois de
janvier je pense que ce qui est bien
c'est que l' architecture de ce procès
permet que toute la première partie soit
consacrée à l écoute des victimes c'est
fondamental de ce qu'elles ont vécu leur
trajectoire leur vie brisée donc c'est
pour ça que c'est peut-être longue je
trouve que c'est bien c'est bien
organisé pour que tout le monde puisse
avoir véritablement sa place je trouve
qu'il ya eu beaucoup de sérénité dans
les débats que les choses se déroulent
bien et nous avons un président de la
cour d'assises totalement exceptionnel
qui va apaiser et arrondir les angles
vous l'événement du jour c'est que ce
procès a commencé dans des conditions
tout à fait satisfaisantes du riz blanc
plus de 1800 parties civiles ont été
constitués pour ce procès hors normes
qui se poursuivra dès lundi
au programme de cette reprise l'audition
d'un enquêteurs de la sous direction
antiterroriste
actualité au proche orient avec ses
frappes aériennes menées par israël sur
la bande de gaza israël évoque une
riposte après des tirs de roquettes
provenant de l'enclavé palestinienne
la tension est vive depuis l'évasion de
palestiniens d'une prison israélienne il
y a quelques jours ci se sont enfuis
quatre ont été retrouvés par les
autorités israéliennes farah mais qui
cinq jours c'est le temps qu'il aura
fallu aux forces de sécurité
israéliennes pour retrouver la trace de
quatre des six évadés de la prison de
guilboa dans le nord est du pays ce
samedi l'état hébreu a annoncé
l'arrestation de zakaria zoubeïdi
l'ancien chef palestinien du fatah et de
mohamed arda membres du djihad islamiste
palestinien branche politique armée qui
demande la création d'un état distinct
de celui d'israël la veille yacoub kadri
et mahmoud arda connu pour être le
cerveau de l'évasion ont été capturés
par les forces israéliennes à peine
arrêter les quatre hommes ont comparu
devant le tribunal de nazareth
les services secrets les procureurs
demandent l'interdiction de la
communication entre l'avocat et son
client
comme
si possible dans des cas de sécurité
très extrême
notre plus grande inquiétude et qu'ils
ont été traités équitablement
qui n'ont pas été blessés ni torturé ils
font actuellement l'objet d'une enquête
des services secrets nous espérons que
le tribunal leur expliquera notre
position à savoir que tant qu'ils ne
nous ont pas rencontré ils ne doivent
pas coopérer aux interrogatoires
en cisjordanie occupée l'annoncé de
l'arrestation des fugitifs a entraîné
une vague de protestations dans certains
villages où les évadés sont érigés en
héros nationaux
malheureusement nous avons reçu la
nouvelle de sa capture et nous étions
bouleversés
mais notre tristesse est mêlé de bonheur
puisque marc webb a pu réaliser cet
exploit en faisant évadés les
prisonniers étaient libres pendant
quatre ou cinq jours
on ne s'attendait pas à ce qu'ils
goûtent un jour à la liberté réalise cet
exploit et brice de systèmes israël
lundi les prisonniers ont fui par un
tunnel creusé sous le lavabo de leur
cellule à l'aide d'une petite cuillère
caché derrière une affiche une évasion
spectaculaire qui n'a pas manqué de
remettre en question l'efficacité des
services de sécurité israéliens et
d'engendrer un regain de tension dans la
région
quelques heures après l'annoncé de
l'arrestation des fugitifs une roquette
a été tirée depuis les territoires
palestiniens vers le sud d'israël
en représailles dans la nuit de vendredi
à samedi ça l'a mené des frappes
aériennes sur la bande de gaza
l'annoncé a été faite cette nuit le
président tunisien va former un nouveau
gouvernement et il n'exclut pas une
réforme prochaine de la constitution les
précisions de sébastien chabal
un bain de foule dans la nuit de samedi
à dimanche avant une annonce très
attendue
par les tunisiens
en ce qui concerne la constitution je la
respecte je respecte les procédures et
je continuerai de respecter les textes
mais il est possible d'introduire des
ajustements au texte dans la foulée le
président confirme la formation
prochaine d'un nouveau gouvernement
après avoir retenu selon ses mots des
personnalités parmi les plus intègres le
25 juillet dernier le même kaïs sayed
limogeait son premier ministre et je lai
le parlement
exaspérés par leur classe politique elle
durement touchée par le malaise social
ambiant les tunisiens avaient salué
cette décision forte
le 24 août le président sayed prolonger
ce gel du parlement jusqu'à nouvel ordre
suscitant l'inquiétude de l'opposition
et de la communauté internationale à
l'image de l'union européenne en visite
à carthage ce vendredi son représentant
youssef borel a fait part de ses
inquiétudes
j'ai transmis au président les
appréhensions européenne appréhension
par rapport à la préservation de
l'acquis démocratique en tunisie seule à
même de garantir la stabilité et la
prospérité du pays le libre exercice du
pouvoir législatif et la reprise de
l'activité parlementaire font partie de
cet acquis et doivent être respectées
le nouveau gouvernement tunisien doit
maintenant rassuré ses partenaires
internationaux mais aussi sa propre
population
la tunisie un pays toujours en
ébullition ce samedi un homme est mort
après s'être immolé par le feu en plein
centre ville de tunis
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
dans 30 minutes pour une nouvelle
édition à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple c'était
une volonté collective vous le savez
pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative on sent du politique il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens
ne s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]